the yes intimacy and what is what is
real and what is not
i suppose you know the conditions have
to be right
of course for for for for love to happen
you know it's much it is much more
difficult to be female i i grant you
that
because the body is more complicated you
know if you're born a woman all these
things happen to you
you're a baby then a child and a girl
and a
girl woman and all these things are
going on it's this constant
opera where the masks keep falling to
the floor throughout your life
who am i i don't know watch out i'm
[__] nuts and then
if you're male you know you're born you
have a finger up your nose and the other
hand on your dick and you get taller and
that is really it
i don't want to make any huge
generalizations
about women you know
no i'm not here to do that it's vulgar
but all i'll say is that they have no
feelings
because it's actually men you'll find
who are far more romantic men
are the people you will hear say i found
somebody
she's amazing if i don't if i don't get
to be with this person
i'm [__] i can't carry on i mean i
know i mean it i
she's totally transformed my life i have
a job i have a flat it
means nothing if i can't stand it i have
to be with her
because if i don't i'm going to end up
in some bedside i'll be alcoholic i'll
have itchy trousers i can't
i can't walk the streets anymore that
is how women feel about shoes
with everything that happens to them and
when they go to bed at 90 years and
years later they do achieve a kind of
real intimacy
where you have to know somebody very
well to be able to say
i hate the way you breathe
where'd you breathe like that it sounds
like it's coming through your [__]
forehead
i haven't slept in 35 years
do you have any idea how fat you
actually are do you do you have any
[__] idea
no you don't do you because your little
face is an island trapped in a sea
a flab
i would stab you to death but i can't
afford to take the two weeks off work
and the arguments do seem to be unfairly
wracked
in in in women's favor because of the i
think the arguments are made in
different places all
male arguments are very early seventies
soviet made unidirectional trundling
behemoths
that say the same thing again and again
and again you know i told you i would be
late on tuesday i told
you i really i said it i heard my own
voice i did say it
i told you where's women
seem to have these amazing slinky
stealth bombers designed by jaguar with
a lovely cream leather interior and
infinite torque
that's why they can respond by saying
yes maybe all right but why is the
fridge door open
i don't understand
i'm not good at violence you know i
think politically if anything i'm
probably liberal
because i'm frightened of everybody you
know i
i i i was in a bar in in london a couple
of years ago it was the summer it was
incredibly hot
like tonight and um i was sitting
outside
and uh this woman came out it was an
attractive woman she came
came out and was she was gonna which she
was she was attractive
in the way that other women would have
said of her well she's attractive in an
obvious way
interestingly a lot of the women who say
that about other women tend to have
hidden their own attractions so well
that you do feel like throwing them a
bread roll but anyway
this young vital person
came out and i found myself looking at
her
i was looking things you're lovely
you're a really lovely looking
human being then i thought don't stay i
don't stare that's rude
but i couldn't help it i looked back and
as i did
her boyfriend walked out who happened to
be very very tall
black and extraordinarily handsome
an amazing looking man wonderful rangy
stride and
chiseled features sort of see green eyes
and a thousand-yard stare
an extraordinary person you know i
couldn't take my eyes off him
i completely forgotten about her
and then i became aware again i thought
christ don't stare it's rude you'll
think you're staring because they're a
mixed race couple or something no that
don't don't don't
i looked away i looked at the other side
of the street and as i did this is all
true a skinhead was walking towards me
now a proper one as well one of the
old-school skinheads you know
who you don't see anymore like
hunchbacks
where did all those people go i think
there's an island somewhere but
he's one of the real ones you know the
people the people who make all their
major decisions with their neck
tattoos on his teeth
he's gonna hit me just for being alive i
can't look there i can't look i can't
look anywhere
and i thought oh no he'll walk by and
he'll say something dreadful to these
people
and i hate these situations it's gonna
be awful oh no no no
he did catch up they all started
chatting to her friends they knew each
other and i overheard one of them say i
hope that drunk doesn't go mental
so
there's a lot of fear around
and i had i had my own thing with some
skinheads years ago you know i was
again in london uh and and these three
guys they go around in groups you know
because they have a lot of highly
classified information to convey to one
another
and yeah
one of them bumped into me very
deliberately shouldered me and
now i'm a rational person usually you
know in that situation i would think
like you i'll go home half a cup of tea
and think about what i would have done
to this person
had they been tied up
but i was too tired and pissed off i
just stood there
and looked at them and they came back
when we had a chat the main thing they
wanted to know was how i proposed to
continue breathing for the next couple
of minutes
and then i did a very male sort of
reckoning you know i did the calculation
i thought right there's three of you
and there's one of me i'm rubbish at
maths by the way
but in record time i worked out that it
would take at least
three of me to defend myself against
a third of one of them
even if he only attacked me with his
arse
i'm not a fighter you know i'm a bleeder
the best i could hope for would be to
drown somebody else in my own blood
if i don't drown myself before you know
i'm not very good at
dealing with those kind of things you
should get good at fighting and i can't
i don't i can't even swim
i can't i can't drive i was going to
learn to drive recently but then i
thought well what if i crash into a lake
but there are a lot of things i don't do
all the wisdom of the world compacted
into a little story and you say there
was a little girl
lost many many miles from home walking
through the woods
laced late at night with the creatures
all hooting and howling in the bushes
around her stepping over the roots of
trees
and she came to the old sky and began to
climb it but it broke you see
it broke and she fell down and but then
when she got herself up she was all
right and you could see
the lights at home and she began to walk
towards
home and then a thing ate her
good night nine nights no you know
you do you like the things that are bad
everybody everybody does and you
you people go a bit mad i think in a
city especially you know
because it gets very stressful people
flank the traffic and people flying
around
you know people go strange they don't
they go for all sorts of weird things
they're very bad for them you know the
gym
and yoga and all those highly
carcinogenic activities that will catch
up with you in the end
or even those really moronic little
books you know you get
now how to release the inner you or find
the 95
habits of totally effective top spots
you don't want to talk to in the first
place
or release your potential that's another
one now that's a very
very dangerous idea you should stay away
from your potential i mean that is
something you should leave absolutely
alone
don't d you'll mess it up it's potential
leave it
and anyway it's like your bank balance
you know you always have a lot less than
you think
if you don't look at it no
leave it as a kind it's a locked door
within yourself
and that's how it should be because then
at least in your mind
the interior will always be palatial you
know
wonderful gleaming marble floors brocade
drapes mullioned windows covered in
mullions whatever they are
and flamingos serving drinks
pianos shooting out canapes into the
mouths of elegant men and women who are
exchanging witticisms
yes this reminds me of the time i was in
budapest with binky
we were trying to steal a goose from the
casino
don't open the door because it won't be
like that
all you can see will be one tiny gray
startling little cat with diarrhea
sitting on a mattress iron sprung bed
with its huge eyes mewing at you
smoking as well probably
as an emphysema landlady untangles her
pop socks in the background
and some terrible guy the color of an
aubergine rounds the corner holding a
milk of beef tea wearing a string vest
and says mainly
[Music]
that's your potential
and then you know there's there's the
extreme version of that
idea of escape people think they'll
emigrate and that's it the
the new life will be somewhere else much
better than here i can't take it anymore
and where would you go people people
fling themselves all over the planet
people end up in australia
why would anybody want to go there
what is the point of that country i was
i usually never leave the house but we
all went to australia recently
the whole family was a ridiculous place
located three quarters of a mile from
the surface of the sun
people audibly crackling as they walk
past you on the street
that's why they all barbecue you don't
need to cook somewhere like that you
just bring this [__] out fling it on a
grill and it bursts into flames
it's not supposed to be inhabited and
when they're not doing that frying
themselves outside they all fling
themselves into the sea
which is inhabited almost exclusively by
things designed to kill you
sharks jellyfish swimming knives they're
all in there
and then you know there's where else
there's
this is the new world you know and the
other part of the new world is america
people think that's got a lot of promise
still
even though we're all a bit funny about
americans now a bit i think the reason
that
happened all that bad feeling about
america
is apart from everything that they've
done
it's because american stupid people
sound stupider than every other kind of
stupid person
some people are just fake but you put up
with them but americans are annoying
when they're thick
because they say well you know i was
just talking about one of those terrible
incidents that happened every
other day in america to say well you
know i was there and the guy came in
and he had like a gun you know and he
was like
shooting and everybody else was totally
dead and you just
it sounds a little divorced from reality
somehow
so i think that's why there's this ill
feeling about the place sometimes
because of everything the administration
has done you know it's like
the really bad flatmate of the world oh
sorry did i break all your [__] i didn't
know it was yours
yeah i'll replace it sometime um
with my stuff and because it's the only
remaining empire
of course you had an empire once britain
had a great empire and
impressively commandeered and
sequestered from the rest of the world
with great style
you just marched in and said you you and
you [__] off we're having tiffin
and everybody's already went hot right
everybody off now that's fine and
it took centuries for people to go hang
on a minute
we live here the american style is
totally different far more insidious
this empire is running a totally
different basis what america does is it
has a nosey in some place some war-torn
fucked-up place
and that looks for oil or chocolate or
whatever it wants
and all the indigenous people obviously
get pissed off
and they begin to meet they begin to
ferment they ring each other up and say
you habbo let's meet and ferment at six
o'clock
in the local bombed out cafe they gather
around and they say
why don't we go i'm good doing a pan
global accent okay
it saves time because america gets
around a lot of places what are we
and this represents poverty
hey listen
hi listen
what are we gonna do about the [__]
imperialistic yankee big dog huh
they come in here they [__] they look
around they take our stuff what we're
gonna i'm talking to you put down the
beans listen what are we gonna do
from china via brooklyn but the um
and then what america does all these
people are talking
a very very gradually builds of
starbucks
around them and then they all become
addicted to latte
and they lose the will to rebel
and then they turn into americans